bienvenue à la brigade criminelle tant
entendu parler du patron
pour tous les flics c'est pour
travailler avec lui que je suis là
des agneaux ah non ah non pas du tout
moi c'est Starling comme la livre le
livre
tu te démerdes comme tu veux mais tu me
branles très vite cette affaire sinon ta
carrière s'arrêtera ici il y a pas une
mute à perdre je l'attrape par la queue
c'est le début d'une série non nos
campeurs ont été tués selon la comptine
une souris verte il a été placé dans la
coquille avant ou après sa mort
quel est le secret que vous cacher huit
suspects dont quatre décédés et trois
morts
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la prison préféré des
Français
excusez-moi c'est un jeune psychopathe
qui aime bien les animaux dernière porte
au bout du couloir
[Musique]
vous avez quoi pour moi
la température 38,5